The joe rogan experience.
Yeah.
Thanks for having me.
Thanks for doing it,
man.
I'm excited.
Uh,
did you have products and stuff that's good to branch out,
dude,
I'll shit that I'm interested in.
Yeah,
just try it again.
But I,
I tried to keep myself interested.
I think that the,
I feel different when I get excited about something like a new exercise or a new
hobby I'm trying or anything.
I get excited when I'm in,
so I try to spread that.
Yeah.
As much as I can.
Cause I tried to think I want to get into other aspects of business.
And that's cool that you does stuff that,
that you're interested in.
Because I like comedy,
I talk about this and my light comedy,
but I understand that is fleeting.
So if everything in comedy went away for you got supplements is shit.
Yeah.
But I don't think comedy is fleeting.
He really thinks,
I think it's like one of the least fleeting leading.
But I'm just saying that's maintenance that it needs maiden,
but thing is in the business like I'm talking about where you know stuff might
be going well,
but then you now work it as much anymore.
I got a theory about that was that I think that shits in the past.
Really?
Yeah.
I don't think that's going to happen anymore.
I think guys would go away because they wouldn't get gigs anymore.
They wouldn't get television shows.
They wouldn't get all these things,
but now everybody promotes themselves.
Everybody has a Twitter account.
Everybody has a website.
Everybody,
when you get fans now they know where they can find you.
It used to be,
if you weren't on television way,
where did he go?
Where is this guy?
Where did he go?
Vanished.
You can't just go to his Facebook page and read a blog that he wrote today.
That's fucking hilarious.
You know?
You can't go and watch a youtube clip that he made when he was fucking around
his backyard with his dog.
That's hilarious.
All that shit is new.
Oh,
you know,
I don't confident.
I'm totally 100% confident.
As confident.
You're going anywhere,
Hannibal Burress,
but the top side and
you've inspired me to give my tiny bottles of lotion for hotels business going
because that's what I'm passionate about.
I'm passionate about tidy bottles of lotion and that seems like a stable
business.
People use it.
I want to get in that.
Yeah,
people do use it.
Someone's got to be selling them that shit.
Yeah,
it's a good point.
And you have some better smelling stuff that a smell and stuff and maybe some
jokes on the lotion.
That's okay.
Too funny though.
You don't want to do jerking off with your lotion and cracking up.
No.
Yeah.
Not that you don't want to use in the middle of it so you don't lose your
stroke.
You don't want to.
Dude loses his stroke when you go limp while jerking off.
Man,
those are tough times,
like getting it up again while you're jerking off.
Well,
that's just a lot of work,
but that's just if you focused,
if you really,
if you've really about making it to your goal,
then you just power through.
That's really what it is.
It seems frivolous,
but it's really just an exercise in achieving your goals.
Fall down nine times.
Get up nine times.
Why did I say they say get up 10 what the Fuck Are you idiots?
Because people fall down a lot.
Get brain damage.
It sounded like you're hurt.
You can't just fall down nine times.
You gonna get fucked up,
man.
Yeah.
Little kids fall down.
The words themselves.
What?
You're a grown man.
You gotta Fall Down Nine Times.
You're not going to break something.
Why are you falling?
So what's that?
What's the balance?
How are you getting tackled all you just straight up fall it.
You got a bump Nissan?
No ankle week.
You've got a weak foot.
Yeah.
People got to get it together to fall down.
Nine Times.
Get up 10 what are you saying?
Yeah.
How does that even work?
It does it.
I don't know.
I guess get up in the morning,
you count that one account and getting up in the morning.
That's what they count.
You can't count that because you get to count lying down in bed then too.
That's fallen down.
Yeah.
They gave her a bitch.
You went to sleep.
Yeah,
man.
So basically what I'm saying is,
fuck that.
Oh,
Dwayne wade commercial.
I've been,
that's what I came here.
So thank you.
I'm glad you're here,
man.
Promote naturebox and say,
fuck that stupid commercial.
Yeah.
Congrats.
The nature of box.
Okay.